mike is in tampa florida hey mike what's
up
hey dave hey dr do you think stick from
the call how are you guys today
better than we deserve how can we help
um
i need a little help with the tie
breaker for your favorite question um
we are baby step two um and i'm debating
on selling my vehicle
um we are we saw the car came on my
wife's car as well
and student loans how much in student
loans
student loans is 30 000. what do you owe
on your cars
uh i owe twelve thousand on my wife's
car and i owe thirty two thousand on
my uh expedition and what's your
household income
i make a hundred and forty thousand plus
vehicle allowance uh
my mileage rate and then my wife makes
50 000 and i have
two side hustles that bring in about 20
000 a year
so 250 grand about that yes
okay and um any other debt
other than these three things on your
mortgage um we actually went
we don't have a mortgage we decided to
wait until uh we got out of debt
and uh no we paid off all of our credit
cards we paid off all of the
medical debt already we are just now on
to the vehicles and the student loans
okay and uh you're fired up about this
and she's not as fired up
yeah well i i drive over a thousand
miles a week guys so i i work from miami
to jacksonville i'm on the road all day
and she's a little concerned that if i
saw the vehicle get something cheaper
it'll break down and my vehicle
allowance my local mileage generally
covers the car payment
and the gas i'm on the other hand on the
fence because
i see debt going way faster okay
all right well you get the vehicle
allowance whether you have a car payment
or not
so comparing it to the car payment is a
is a fool's trap don't get caught in
that trap
but um you can afford these cars and you
can afford this debt
you can afford to pay off this debt i
mean you got uh 74 000
worth of debt making 250 ought to be
debt free in a year
that was the idea yes i figured under 15
months okay now let's pretend let's
pretend you're there
so that's probably what you ought to do
by the way okay i think i think your
wife wins the argument
um as long as you're both on board with
doing beans and rice and getting out of
debt in a year
yes sir okay now the second thing is
this
you need to drive because you are
destroying
the value of whatever vehicle you drive
you need to drive the least possible
expensive car
for purposes of your business that will
get the job done now let's put that in
air quotes
get the job done the definition of
getting the job done
when i make 250 000 a year i don't need
to be driving a freaking smart car
i'll be in a chiropractor's office as
much time as you spend in a car
you don't need to be driving a piece of
crap and broke down on the side of the
highway
okay so get the job done is a nice
comfortable reliable vehicle
knowing that whatever i spend on it i
might as well pile that up in 100
bills in the front yard and light it on
fire because you're going to destroy
the value of whatever you drive agreed
yes sir
agreed and so next time i buy a car it's
probably not going to be a 40
000 car to destroy
absolutely some decision yeah no i'm
picking on you i'm just saying going
forward
that's what i would do because you just
say i'm a road warrior even if you want
a nice car
in the driveway and a road warrior car
for driving that i'm destroying
i'm okay with that
yeah that's what that's what i thought
of i thought i was getting like a
smaller car and she said that i would be
miserable and i
agree you said the same thing yeah i
just don't want you in a piece of crap
that's not reliable and also don't want
you in something that's
you know you spend a lot of time in a
car it needs to ride good it needs to
drive well good
it needs to be um you know it's it's a
road car i mean
but you don't you know you wouldn't
drive a you you wouldn't go buy a
hundred thousand dollar mercedes
and turn it into a ten thousand dollar
mercedes every three years
because that's what you're doing because
that's what you're doing so
that's the balance here you just gotta
it's a business decision
what you put on the road now you may
reach a point with your income
and your wealth that you have a road car
and a weekend driver
that's a that's your cool car that's at
home that's a 40 or a 50 000
car that's paid for sitting in your
driveway and then you get a brand new
what camry or avalon or something to
your own one there you go yeah and just
get you you know two-year-old camry and
our
uh um you know a nice honda accord
loaded up or whatever i don't care what
it is i mean
oh you know caddy yeah those caddies are
pretty nice they're doing good
uh just knowing you're gonna burn the
depreciation off that sucker
to the ground whatever it is and you
know what you're looking for there is
like you're looking for gas mileage too
yeah because you're you're running the
wheels
you're just running up down the road
thousand miles man i mean that's you
start putting 50 000 miles a year on a
car
pretty much gone right i mean even if
you take care of it you can get a lot of
life out of it but my point is the
value goes away right quickly yep
because nothing destroys value like
mileage
so um that that or you know driving it
up through the field
yes jumping creeks or you know stuff
like that that's the john dolonie wave
might be some rednecks sitting here that
have done something like that i don't
know anybody like that personally but
they're in this room